welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and we just got a fresh new trailer for
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania this
movie opens in just over a month and I
cannot wait to talk about all these new
juicy details that you may have missed
in this trailer so let's Jump On In
shall we but first of course do not
forget to hit up new rockstarsmerch.com
or you can pick up a new shirt that is
amazing our latest Obsession shirts are
the best but we have a black panther
we're kind of forever one that I may or
may not be still around go check that
out but let's get into that damn trailer
shall we
you're an interesting man
Scotland you're an Avenger
[Music]
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time
like me we opened our shot of San
Francisco the home of Scotland the pims
and the van dimes as the MTU continues
its West Coast narrative after MCU
projects like the Guardians of Galaxy
holiday special She-Hulk and shung Ching
like West Coast Avengers are common
people and a voiceover of King reveals
to us that Scott feels a lot of regret
over his lost time with Cassie while he
was stuck in the quantum realm something
that King himself seems to be able to
relate to possibly implying that he
wishes to escape the quantum realm to go
conquer you know as a big person
but as he's saying this we see that
Scott laying at Hope Van Dyne have been
invited to the humanitarian global
Service Awards likely for their
contributions to the quantum realm
science that the Avengers utilize to go
back in time and save half the universe
I'd say that's a little bit of
recognition don't you and this guy on
the right of the frame holding the boom
mic kind of gives me Stan Lee Vibes I
don't know about you like I'm not sure
if this was intentional or not but let's
just say it was we miss you papa Lee all
right B then we see Scott about to
answer a call from his daughter Cassie
in some type of library but he does take
a moment to answer the phone call in
order to stare at a picture of the
younger Cassie Lang that he left behind
played by actress Abby Ryder Fortson in
the first two Ant-Man films implying to
me that little Cassie might be a factor
that K uses to manipulate Scott Lang
because if you think about it Scott did
a Time Heist to save half the entire
universe but he couldn't save little
Cassie so I think that we could be
seeing King the Conqueror dangling the
possibility of stealing a little Cassie
variant for Scott from another timeline
but only if Scott gets what Kang needs
because that star Lord guy got a new
Gamora right so the Multiverse has an
infinite amount of Scott's tots oh my
God that was a horrible episode of The
Office I just got flashbacks
and I can see why why Scott might be
missing little Cassie because little
Cassie didn't have a criminal record
much like his implied when we see
Teenage Cassie being released from a
jail cell but hey you know like father
like daughter am I right but much like
Scott was imprisoned for trying to undo
the fraud of his old employer mysticorp
I have a feeling that Cassie might have
been arrested for doing a good thing
like her dad I mean her layers of green
and blue over a t-shirt of the planet
Earth kind of make me feel like Cassie
could be a bit of a Teenage Eco Warrior
it might have been arrested trying to
save the planet at a protest gone wrong
or something I mean the Atlantic Ocean
is front and center here so maybe the
emergence of Namor and the atlanteans
during wakanda forever affected Cassie
to fight against pollution fight for the
Atlantean people and thank you to better
help for sponsoring this video do you
know why we love a team up so much yes
it's the banter in the Combos and the
cool slo-mo group action shots but
mainly it's easier to Take On The World
when you've got help getting help is
good and now thanks to better help
getting help is easy too Better Health
is the world's largest therapy service
and it's 100 online but better help you
can tap into a network of over 25 000
license and experienced therapists who
can help you with a wide range of issues
to get started you just answer a few
questions about what you need and what
your preferences are for therapy that
way better health can match you with the
right therapist from their Network once
that's done you can talk to your
therapist however you feel comfortable
whether it's via text chat phone or
video call you can message your
therapist at any time and you can
schedule live sessions when it's
convenient for you and if your therapist
isn't the right fit for any reason you
can switch to a new therapist at no
additional charge better help let you
get the same professionalism and quality
that you expect from in-office therapy
but with a therapist who is custom
picked for you with more schedule week
flexibility and at a more affordable
price to get 10 off your first month you
can scan the QR code click the link in
the description or just go to
betterhelp.com new rockstars that's
better
h-e-l-p.com Slash new rockstars for 10
off your first month of therapy and
think better help again for sponsoring
this video but anyways moving on Cassie
can be you seen wearing the same shirt
as he flicks her weird machine on
supposedly sending a signal to the
quantum realm like she says in the last
trailer and as that blue glowing ball of
light floats in the air you might notice
that there is a keyboard connected to
the console which is how I'm assuming
Cassie has been able to chat with
whoever she's been signaling in the
quantum realm she's chatting with
strangers on the internet a stranger
that could quite possibly have been the
big-headed Modoc who was revealed to be
none other than Darren cross in the MCU
a little bit later in the trailer who
apparently survived after having his
body crushed and shrunk into Oblivion in
the most gnarly and freaking horrific
ways that I've ever seen in the MCU
after kidnapping Cassie to get to Scott
so we could be looking at a similar
situation here with cross wanting to get
revenge on the man who made him a big
head machine man with little dangly legs
this of course is not modox origin the
comics as Modoc is originally the
scientist George Tarleton who is mutated
by aim to become their mental organism
only designed for computing complicated
nerd [ __ ] until Modoc went crazy and
became the mental organism only designed
for killing instead of computing so you
know turn that c into a k and yeah
you're gonna be dead today oh just made
that up I got a big head like ligodoc
but my big head gang brother Tommy
bechtold has
explainer on just who mode
I can check that out if you haven't but
anyway since we know that Darren cross
has been getting more and more crazier
due to his exposure to his own shrinking
radiation having cross substitute for
total said in the MCU doesn't make sense
here but I am very glad that they ended
up giving him a mask with a more comic
accurate phase on it because seeing a
big human face is very jarring and I
don't think I can look at that for uh
two and a half hours of a month with you
so it's quite disgusting everybody says
that it looks like George Lopez in a
shark born Lava Girl I'm gonna have to
agree with you not that it looks bad
it's just you know jarring but moving on
we can also see that the room that
they're in is filled with machines and
what appears to be a luminescent ant
farm to the right of the glowing ball
which can be seen better as everything
gets sucked into the Vortex and it
appears that Cassie was working to carry
on the family business but unfortunately
thanks to Kang there's been some
downsizing but let's keep watching who
are you
I'm the man who can give you the one
thing you want
time
I can rewrite existence
and shatter timelines and we are finally
down on the quantum realm and we get a
great slow reveal of Kang with his blue
face shield his helmet and face shield
seem to be similar to the suits worn by
the Time heisters and Avengers end game
and the mass of the members of the
Guardians of the Galaxy not named yondu
where in space to survive this makes me
feel even more like Kang is a little bit
of a Tony Stark wannabe especially after
knowing that Heathrow remains had an
Iron Man helmet in his office and some
low-key concept art and notice how his
eyes turn blue when using his iconic
blue mask making me suspect of the scars
on his face could have been due to a
surgery that he underwent to install
this nanite technology into his very
body technology that is linked to his
nervous system in response to his mental
commands which is again something that
Tony Stark was very interested in doing
with his Mark 42 armor in Iron Man 3 and
we now see keg appearing to speak
directly to Scott Lang telling him that
I can give you what you want time and
before we we get this amazingly dope
wide shot of King City that kind of
feels like a mashing of famous Star Wars
locations Coruscant in Lando's Cloud
City on the planet bespin I can totally
see director Peyton Reed being inspired
by those because he is no stranger to
the Star Wars Universe after directing
one of the most memorable and amazing
episodes of the Mandalorian ever by
bringing Luke Skywalker back from the
past to go kick to mass we then get the
shot of Kang's pyramid structure that we
saw from an earlier trailer which is for
sure inspired by the character's love of
ancient Egyptian culture in the comics
which of course causes Kane to go back
in time to become the ancient Egyptian
pharaoh Rama Tut only to be chased Away
by The Fantastic Four in his first
appearance and Janet Van Dyne mentioning
that Kane can rewrite existence and
shatter timelines is of course the truth
as we've seen it happen in Loki with he
remains at the Citadel at the end of
time but let's keep on rolling
you cannot trust him I don't care who
this guy is I just lost so much
a second chance
and Scott laying apparently has the
ability to make clones of himself in
this movie like some sort of Home Run
Naruto hybrid man which is a pretty cool
skill to have especially when it's gonna
come in real use of this movie as he
assembles a massive Army of Ant-Man to
rush towards this strange yellow glowing
energy source and building a tower of
Ant-Man clones to reach it much like
ants stack on top of each other in real
life to make these weird Eiffel Tower
formations to reach things and and might
help other ants get to different places
and whatnot it's actually pretty
interesting and I like this imagery that
they use and as K and Darren cross Modoc
lead Scott and Cassie towards this Cliff
you can see them emerge from a Blue
Portal from what looks like Kane's base
a portal that looks suspiciously similar
to the portals made by the Tesseract
whenever beings like Thanos used it to
instantaneously travel I mean since both
Howard and Tony Stark were Tesseract
scientists who use Tesseract power to
power all their technology and Kang
seems to be a Tony Stark Super Fan for
the future I can definitely see Kang
possibly using their research to learn
how to unlock the ability to make
portals that can go anywhere that he
wants as well as power the technology
within his suit and the suits of his
soldiers and with a partner like Modoc
who was literally made in the comics to
study the Cosmic Cube I can see Modoc
helping King Master this Tesseract
energy source portaling technology and
when Scott and team Cassie hug you can
see these strange red crystals in the
background which sort of reminds me of
the red crystals that can be seen into
her mamu's Realm of the dark dimension I
wonder if there's like some type of dark
connection there let me make this easy
for you
he will bring me what I need
or everything you call a life
and the PIM Family takes a much needed
vacation ride together on the back of a
flying Quantum realm avatar creature the
creature's Wings Rush against the water
creating a beautiful blue glow and while
this could very well be the
bioluminescence of some you know native
Plankton or whatever I'm wondering if
the land itself is brimming with blue
cosmic energy much like the land of
wakanda was after the vibrania meteorite
hit and you know enriched the soil I
wonder if that's like a magic water
that'd be really interesting then as we
see Scott forming this Eiffel Tower of
Ant-Man to reach this glowing power
source we can see that it's surrounded
by these rings with markings on them
similar to the markings found in one of
the quantumania logos this being the
case I'm assuming that this is some type
of quantum realm power generator as it
appears to function similarly to the
shield power generator found on Asgard
in Thor the Dark World and much like the
dark elves sought to destroy that
generator it seems like Scott may be
seeking to do the same because for a
split second you can see what looks like
a blaster of some sort emerged from
Scotland's wrist implying that Scott
wants to destroy this structure either
4K or to stop can then we see Cassie
standing in front of a yellow portal
possibly acting as a natural Quantum
tunnel back to the big people world
where all the bills are
but the cracks are on the edges make me
feel like this could possibly be related
to the cracks in the veil from Miss
Marvel and then Scott and hope share the
classic Clint and Natasha forehead touch
but the last time that happened one of
those two died so uh it's not looking
good for your boy Scott especially as he
uh gets his ass beat thoroughly uh by
the end of the trailer
[Music]
you may not want her to watch this we
had a deal
you thought you could win
as Kane is looking out into the Horizon
it looks like he's watching one of his
blue glowing ships being shot down by a
green blowing ship presumably team
Ant-Man and as Kang's fleets of ships
take off I couldn't help but notice how
the blue convex design of the ship's
Windows look similar to the rounded blue
helmets of Kang soldiers possibly
implying that both the ships and the
soldiers are similarly designed pieces
of Technology with his army being a
robot army similar to you know Tony
Stark's Ultron program or the Ultron box
in the Illuminati headquarters and if
Avengers King Dynasty is on the way as
is implied by the trailer's use of the
words a new Dynasty The Avengers are
going to need an army of aliens monsters
or robots to smash because Disney cannot
have the Avengers slaughtering actual
human beings not since that whole
Scarlet Witch Fiasco and then Kang makes
his assault on this red foresty area in
the quantum realm that could possibly be
this area from the first trailer and
could possibly be where those red
crystals from earlier came from during
that Lang family hug but I have a
feeling all that red could imply the
presence of chaos energy being a
factorist especially considering how
Scott's clones unravel similarly to how
mantis and Mr Fantastic unraveled due to
the Red Energy users in both Avengers 3
and Doctor Strange 2. and if this is the
case I have a feeling that this Army of
Scots could be a result of chaos energy
probability magic with Scott generating
a clone that pops up whenever he needs
to make a choice so if for instance
Scott has the options of going either
left or right a clone will pop up that
allows him to do both at the same time
but anyways before Scott is able to go
through this yellow portal like Cassie
was about you earlier in the trailer it
seems like Kang blasts him away and
gives him that beat down that we see at
the end of the trailer symbolically
stomping on Scott like a man would stomp
on an ant hearkening back to what Nick
Fury said to Loki in Avengers 1 and
boot but not before we see a glimpse of
Cassie in her purple suit doing a
dramatic hero jump and dangling off of
an edge that reveals a futuristic
cityscape of the quantum realm very
similar to that of the Sovereign race as
Baby Groot nearly falls off the edge to
his death and we get another look at
Modoc who has two laser cannons jutting
out of the sides of his chair kind of
like cross's Yellow Jacket armor add
laser arms as well
I don't have to win
[Music]
and as Canyons got fight Scott says that
his goal isn't beating King it's making
sure that Kang loses which is a lesson
that Scott probably learned from Doctor
Strange after Doctor Strange used that
mentality to best the mcu's first
Multiverse corporate The Dread dormammu
and finally before Kang shoots out blue
blast to end the trailer he floats on
the ground on this blue energy disc
similar to the blue energy that Reed
Richards portaled in with in Multiverse
Madness and since Kang is supposedly a
descendant of Nathaniel Richards in the
comics there could be some type of
relationship there but that is the
breakdown for the Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania trailer are you guys excited
for this movie what was your favorite
part of the trailer thank you guys so
much for watching this video you can
follow me at mastertonment on Twitter
most importantly you can follow us
wherever you are on the social medias
but again thank you guys so much for
watching this video I love you guys so
much and I'll see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]